Moments ago, Chinese President Xi Jinping,
as you can see here,
landing in Moscow for his face
to face meeting with President Putin.
On the agenda, obviously, Ukraine,
she said that he believes
China is actively promoting peace talks
while Putin
was in the Russian occupied Ukrainian city
of Mariupol over the weekend.
Says he welcomes China's, quote, readiness
to make
a meaningful contribution
to the settlement of the crisis.
The White House is John Kirby
joins us now.
Good morning, John.
Are you expecting any tangible agreements
to come out of this summit
with Putin and Xi?
Difficult to know, Caitlin.
Obviously,
we're not part of these discussions,
so we'll see what these two leaders
actually come out and say
at the end of this.
I guess it's going to be a couple of days
here of of their meeting and that agenda.
So we'll see.
But as you know,
we've we've been very, very public
about any concerns about some sort
of a cease fire announcement.
Right now, we all want to see peace.
We all want to see this war end.
It could end today
if Mr. Putin did the right thing.
But a cease fire called
right now would basically just ratify
Russia's conquest and give Mr.
Putin more time to reequip and retrain
and and restart operations at a time
and a place of his choosing.
So if they call for a cease fire, you believe Ukraine should and will reject that?
Yes, we do.
And we would reject it as well.
We think that
that's an unacceptable outcome right now.
Obviously, we want the fighting to stop.
We want the war to be over.
And as I said, it could end today
if Mr. Putin would do the right thing.
But to call for a cease fire right
now, basically ratifies
what they've been able to grab inside
Ukraine and gives them time and space
to prepare for future operations.
And that's
just not going to be acceptable.
John, do you think this meeting could be
a venue where they announce that China
may start providing weapons to Ukraine
or to Russia to use in Ukraine?
We don't believe it's in China's
best interest to do that.
We can't
we can't envision how they would think
that it's in their best interests
to help Mr.
Putin continue to slaughter
more innocent Ukrainians.
So we don't want to see that again.
We'll see what these leaders come out with
and what they say
at the end of these discussions.
We're going to watch this very,
very closely.
Again, we have communicated
privately to the Chinese
we've certainly communicated it publicly
that that would not be an outcome
that's to the betterment not only of China
and their interests,
but certainly to the Ukrainian people
and to the whole idea of peace.
What does it say to you that after
the International Criminal Court
issued that arrest warrant for Putin,
that she still showed up in Russia?
It clearly did not deter that visit.
But also, you saw Putin over the weekend
in Mariupol in all of these other cities.
I think you have to
it's your first question.
I think he got to keep this relationship
in some sort of context here.
These are two nations
who chafe and bristle at the idea of U.S.
leadership
or U.S. influence around the world.
They don't
they don't like playing by the rules
that the world order has in place.
And they want to challenge
U.S. leadership.
This is a marriage of convenience,
not of affection.
These are two countries that don't have
a heck of a whole lot of trust
between one another.
But they find common cause in pushing
back on the West and pushing back on
American leadership.
So, again, we'll see what they decide
to do when they come out with this.
And as for Mr. Putin's visit to Mariupol.
Mariupol is far away from the front lines
of the fighting in the south
and in the east.
It was a convenient excuse for him
to go in advance of Xi's visit
to show that he's still the commander
in chief, that he's still in charge,
and that his military still has occupied
territory inside Ukraine.
There's no doubt that
that he could see for himself,
or we would hope
that he would see for himself
how badly his military is actually doing,
where the fighting is actually occurring.
And not most of that is right up now
in the Donbass near a town called Back.
The White House wanted President
Xi to also speak
with President Dolinsky
to get the Ukrainian perspective in this.
Any indication that's going to happen?
We haven't seen any confirmation of it.
Obviously, President Xi would be the one
to announce that if he's going to do it.
But we absolutely have been suggesting it
for quite some time.
And we'd love to see that happen.
I mean, if you're going to go to Moscow
and you're going to sit down
for three days with President Putin
and you're going to get his perspective
on a war that he started
and that he could finish today,
you ought to pick up the phone at the very
least and talk to President Zelensky
and get the Ukrainian perspective here.
What we've been saying
from the very beginning,
if this comes down to some
kind of negotiated settlement of some sort
and some place at some time,
it's got to be nothing about Ukraine
without Ukraine.
So Ukraine has got to be central
to those discussions.
Their perspectives
have to be heard and respected
so we absolutely want President
Xi to reach out
and get a little bit of the views
and perspective of Ukraine here.
It's been about a week since President
Biden said
he was going to speak to President
Xi soon.
Is that call and scheduled yet, John?
It hasn't been scheduled, Caitlin,
but the president very much wants to have
another conversation with President Xi.
It's really important
that we keep these lines
of communication open
between the United States and China,
the most consequential bilateral
relationship in the world.
President wants to keep those lines
open. Will do that.
And he'll have a call with President
Xi at the appropriate time.
What is the appropriate time?
Because he said back in mid-February
after the U.S.
down to that surveillance balloon,
that he would speak to him soon.
He said last we could speak to him soon.
So as the US tried to schedule the call
on, the Chinese have been unwilling
or what's going on here?
No, there's been no logistics.
There's been
no there's been no setting it up.
We we maintain that we're going to have
another discussion with President Xi.
The president wants to do
that, wants to keep those lines open
and at the appropriate time,
we'll reach out
and we'll see
if we can get a call on the schedule.
These are two men
that also know each other
for quite some time
when they were both vice
presidents of their respective countries.
They had a good meeting in Bali,
a good discussion.
We'd like to continue that discussion.
We'd like to make sure that this
bilateral relationship is serving
not only the best interests
of the American people but also the world.
And this is a relationship that needs to
be handled in a responsible, mature way.
We want to get back to that,
but we're just going to have to wait
and and do that at the right time.
Speaking of open
lines of communication, we're seeing North
Korea continue to fire off projectiles.
Is it still accurate to say there's
been no contact between the Biden
administration and North Korea?
Not for lack of
try and enough for lack of interest.
Caitlin, we maintain that we would still,
without precondition,
be willing to sit down
and with the North Korean regime
and try to find a diplomatic way
to reduce the nuclear tensions
on the peninsula
and to see the verifiable denuclearization
of of North Korea.
But they have yet to show any interest
in that whatsoever,
any communication whatsoever.
Quite the contrary.
As you rightly noted, their firing off
ballistic missiles.
Now, here, largely in a reaction to us
and our Republic of Korea exercises
that we're conducting right now.
In fact,
I think those exercises are wrapping up.
All right, John Kirby,
thanks for your time this morning.
Joining us now from Taiwan, CNN senior
international correspondent Will Ripley.
Well, hello.
What should we expect to see today
in this meeting between Xi
and Putin?
Well, certainly on the surface, it's
going to be quite a lavish affair.
This is an official state visit
going on for three days.
And I bet Vladimir
Putin is very happy to see Xi Jinping.
I mean, this is his best friend
in the world right now, considering,
you know, the potential to be tried on
war crimes charges.
You know, condemnation by the West,
you know, growing
allegations of of just barbaric behavior
with him at the helm.
And yet you have the Chinese president
showing up, talking about,
you know, working with Putin
to safeguard the international order,
a journey of friendship,
cooperation and peace.
You know, it's it's it just really is
so thick.
You know, you could slice it with a knife.
And yet this is what, you know,
the Russian public, the Chinese public,
this is what they're being fed And this
and so this build up of this
this no limits partnership
between these two.
Again, you know, she continues
just to really put so much you know,
of head of his own credibility, really,
in this relationship with Vladimir Putin.
Now, the question that we need to to see
if it will be answered publicly
or if it'll come out later
is whether they talk about lethal weapons,
which Putin needs because his troops
are running out of ammunition
and other things.
And will China be willing to give Russia
the weapons that it would need
that could actually turn turn things
around for them on the ground potentially?
This is the big concern.
And also this Chinese peace plan
that that she is going there touting.
All right.
Basically, Ukraine says this plan
needs to begin with a Russian withdrawal.
But what China is calling for
is for Russia to basically be given
the land that they've already taken.
Yeah.
And notable, given that John Kirby
said earlier, even if China does
publicly propose a cease fire, once again,
he the U.S.
is Ukraine should reject it.
And he said the US will reject it as well.
Yeah, it's it's
these are two men,
two strong men up against the West.
And with each visit, with each, you know,
each side is digging in their heels.
It's really pretty troubling
for a lot of people watching the direction
of of these two polar opposites
in the world right now.
All right.
Will Ripley in Taiwan for us this morning.
Well, thank you
very much. Appreciate you joining us.